[Music]
about working with dummy house up and
going oh she's great man I'm saying I
love her story meaning as in you know
it's inspiring it's a blessing that she
called me and gave me the opportunity to
hit the stage with her I got a lot of
surprises I'm coming witty I'm lighting
I stays up the last show as always how
can say it's like New Year's Eve every
night like it's just explosive fireworks
some cities I'm a coma certain surprises
yet the comes find out everybody is
buzzing about this JLo cardi B
collaboration what can you tease
everything top secret you're saying I
could tell you this cello cello got some
new music coming I want to thank JLo for
letting me be you know saying one of the
producers amongst other great ones and a
feature I'm saying on the record and I'm
I'm grateful so she got some coming she
got some coming we're excited and we saw
cardi B on the Instagram to cardi B he's
having a moment
yeah cardi B man she's doing a thing may
God bless her man you know to get in the
game you know these are these are the
rewards and the accomplishments that we
all work hard for he's saying from her
Hot 100's you know I remember getting my
first number one my first hot 100 number
one I know the feeling I know how
exciting that is and all it does is it's
a drive to make you keep going more and
more and more and more so it's like man
number love for cardi B and all the new
artists out there doing that thing now I
got to know has Assad made it to the set
of the four yet stay tuned tonight maybe
are you ready
listen that boys side
be ready we up to something before this
Thursday 8 o'clock make sure you ready
[Music]